this is Startalk hey guys its death up
and yes we are here the north ear you're
getting wedding for Startalk live with
Bill Nye
Eugene Mirman May Higgins anywhere and
dr. Jim Green and I am so freaking
excited I'm in the I guess it's not fun
a green room but dressing room we got
some beers because we so fancy and
Heather and Rob are here we actually saw
bill 9 on the way in and I think it's
for DJ room investors so it's gonna be a
parade it's gonna be awesome
yeah here we go
Oh
I just met my and and weird and dr. Jim
Green and Eugene Mirman I didn't need to
mean it meet Maeve Higgins yet but she
seems really cool too so I'm very
excited and it was awesome I didn't take
a whole lot of video because they were
doing sound check so I will try to get a
little bit more after the show but it
was awesome just to meet those people
and Andy weir is just the nicest dude in
the world they were all so so so great
and it was just an amazing experience
and dr. Jim Green gave me a NASA pen
that I've left over there so I can't
show you but I'll show you later but it
was amazing and just so so cool I got to
meet bill nye the guy who has had such a
massive impact on my trajectory I mean I
went from being a preschooler watching
his show every day after school to
becoming an aerospace engineer working
on satellites every day because I fell
in love with science at such a young age
so this is just I'm gonna need a minute
Pat but it's awesome
and I'm here with Heather Heather
general thoughts on the show
before it happens second year in a row
here at Startalk um fantastic wonderful
guests this year we got another NASA
person we've got an author with two
comedians and we've got Bill Nye the
Science Guy what more could you ask for
what's the word nerd nerd nerd glorious
Heather yeah Heather made-up word and
they're glorious I'm gonna put that on a
t-shirt can I sit
we need nerd for nerds glorious March
coming 20 sometime we did we just did
the soundcheck
we went out met anywhere and Eugene
Mirman and Bill Nye and dr. Jim Green
the planetary scientists and they're all
gonna talk space missions and spare
movies tonight so star talk radio in the
house hey Rob you've got to me it's
still nice people and oh yes and you got
some minutes RRR sighs all right yeah we
we get the autographs we are we are so
Hollywood now yes much Hollywood very
glamour that does flavor central stuff
got hair sticking up yeah I can't
believe I did the prom pose for the bill
my picture I'm walking around with a
Martian potato
potato
I'm here with dr. Jemma green NASA's
director the Planetary Sciences Division
dr. green first time on Startalk yeah it
was wonderful yeah it was completely
uncontrollable yeah it was it was a
great time we had so much fun listening
you guys talked backstage we're just
gonna get beeped out so I got a half
minute nine I'm feeling well I call it
Planet X
yeah we still don't know that it's there
there's indications that are very
exciting for us to contemplate there may
be other explanations but you have told
the the community or science community
go find it let's figure out where it's
at and they're on it I think in the next
several years we might have a good shot
of finding another planet or not in our
solar system absolutely they're really
looking forward to hearing more about it
import of the future thank you very much
insane guys oh my god so much adrenaline
unreal unreal she's so much fun thank
you so much to start off thank you Bill
Nye Eugene Mirman Andy weir after Jim
Garrett May pagans do it incredible and
thank you to everybody at Startalk that
lets Heather and I come in have the keys
to the kingdom for a night it was truly
amazing and to meet these people that I
have looked up to for so long it's just
incredible so thank you guys so much but
as always I hope you guys have a
wonderful rest of the week stay well
stay off them and I will see you next
time
oh and keep looking up
this is Startalk